bonjour David Lyna merci beaucoup d'être
notre première invité politique de cette
semaine spéciale consacrée évidemment au
104e congrès des maires de France qui
s'ouvrent aujourd'hui vous êtes maire
les républicains de Cannes présidents de
cette Association des Maires de France
en étant ensemble pendant
une partenariat avec la presse régionale
représentée par Fabrice dessert Redon du
groupe Ebra
bonjour David bonjour le groupe Evra
sont les journaux régionaux de l'Est de
la France on leur dit on va évidemment
longuement parler de ce congrès des
maires de France David l'islam mais
d'abord un mot sur l'actualité la
majorité des migrants de l'océan Viking
placées en zone d'attente dans le Var
ont été remis en liberté en application
du droit faute de pouvoir statuer sur
leur cas en temps et en heure 26 mineurs
non accompagné ont fugué est-ce que pour
vous l'État infailli c'est pas une
surprise malheureusement c'est c'est pas
pour être polémique moi je ne cesse de
dire que aujourd'hui l'exécutif devrait
beaucoup plus s'occuper d'exécuter les
choses on a exécutif qui ne cesse de
légiférer de faire des effets d'annonce
on en est à la 22e loi sur l'immigration
depuis 1986 la 14e loi depuis 20 ans une
succession d'annonces théâtrale très
souvent avec des déclarations martiales
mais dans la réalité ce que l'on
constate c'est que notre appareil d'État
dans le pays qui prélève plus
qu'ailleurs d'impôts et de charge dans
le pays qui a le record de la dépense
publique et notre appareil d'État est
défaillant dès qu'il faut exécuter les
choses on a une crise sanitaire on a une
abondance d'argent public quoi qu'il en
coûte et on a pénurie de tout ce qui est
nécessaire les masques l'hydratation etc
on a des incendies cet été tout ce qui
relève des départements et des communes
et dotées sur les 10 mais on a pénurie
de Canada on a actuellement des
problèmes dans les hôpitaux pénuries de
médicaments et je pourrais multiplier
les exemples
du mauvaise gestion gouvernementale où
est-ce que c'est le droit qui n'est pas
adapté à un
chaos dans lequel on est tombé depuis
des années on le sait très bien qu'il y
a des contradictions juridiques en
arbitres pas par référendum alors qu'il
faudrait faire un grand référendum pour
maîtriser notre politique de peuplement
bien intégré bien accueillir bien
assimilé réduire le nombre d'immigrés
sur le sur le territoire national ça
transcende tous les clivages d'ailleurs
en fait en réalité justement dans le
sujet vous semblez aborder dans le sens
de Gérard Collomb ancien maire de Lyon
ancien ministre de l'Intérieur qui
estiment que sur les migrants
il y a du dessaler et qu'on n'a pas pris
les choses en main d'abord c'est genre
colon qui abonde dans le sens de ce que
un certain nombre à dire depuis
longtemps et
c'est une enfin c'est une évidence
aujourd'hui sur la forme vous êtes
d'accord parce que regardez sur les
titres légaux de mémoire mais on peut
tout vérifier maintenant rapidement il y
a eu un million 200000 titres sur les 5
dernières années c'était un record mais
sur l'immigration illégale on sait très
bien qu'on ne maîtrise plus rien sur les
occultés F alors moi j'en parlais depuis
longtemps malheureusement l'actualité de
façon tragique à rappeler cette réalité
on était à 21% seulement d'exécution des
obligations de quitter le territoire
français il y a 5 ans on est à 6%, le
président de la République avait annoncé
ce qui était complètement fou d'ailleurs
100%. donc on voit bien qu'il y a à la
fois et en fait on a on est passé de 21
à 6 donc il y a deux problèmes il y a
des contradictions juridiques y compris
en droit européen avec la
surinterprétation du droit au mouvement
famille familial à la famille par donc
les institutions européennes mais
parallèlement
au sein de la zone euro et de l'Europe
on est les plus défaillants dans
l'exécution des choses donc il y a un
problème franco-français d'organisation
problème de l'appareil de l'État il y a
un problème de clarification du droit
mais il y a un problème surtout
d'organisation
je n'ai parlé de pénurie pénurie de
magistrats enfin comment cet état qui
n'a jamais autant prélevé vous avez vu
qu'on passe on vient de passer les 45,2
% de prélèvement obligatoire n'a jamais
le nombre de magistrats qu'il faut c'est
à dire qu'on est toujours défaillant sur
le régalien ce qui s'est arrivé ce
week-end c'était prévisible et c'était
en contradiction totale avec les
déclarations une fois de plus
très martial de l'exécutif du ministère
de l'Intérieur et c'est ce qui alimente
cette crise civique nous on recentrait
bien la crise civique aujourd'hui on
sent bien la tension dans la société une
des causes majeures de la crise civique
c'est la différence entre les discours
très emphatiques très exagéré vous savez
nous laisserons plus passer ça nous
condamnant que la plus grande fermeté
toutes ces formules qu'on entend qui
sont démonétisées et la réalité des
actes et les citoyens les habitants les
gens on regarde ça on se fout de nous et
on a l'impression en plus que l'État est
défaillant dans ses fonctions
régaliennes est faible avec les forts et
fort avec les faibles vous faites avec
cette vitesse vous êtes sanctionné ce
qui est normal systématiquement vous
êtes solvable et puis vous avez
l'impression que des personnes sont hors
du champ du droit et ça je crois
vraiment que c'est un problème majeur et
que indépendamment des discussions
juridiques administratives politiques
polémiques tout ce que l'on veut
l'essentiel aujourd'hui est de que
l'exécutif fasse beaucoup moins de
théâtre et s'intéresse beaucoup plus à
l'exécution des choses ça fait monter
les extrêmes ce qui s'est passé
les extrêmes ça amène à la Tony civique
c'est-à-dire des gens qui ne vont plus
voter ça amène à l'exagération sur les
réseaux sociaux et c'est mais c'est un
exemple parmi tant d'autres tant
d'autres tant d'autres on va parler du
Congrès des mères avant de parler des
dossiers ils sont nombreux
préoccupations à des élus il y aura une
séquence consacrée à l'Ukraine lors de
ce congrès les mères ont beaucoup
contribué à des réfugiés Ukrainiens sur
le sol aujourd'hui comment on pouvait
aider l'Ukraine à votre niveau les mères
ont de France ont été je crois
exemplaires sur tout le territoire pour
accueillir les réfugiés donc
ukrainiens et mais aussi pour envoyer de
l'aide humanitaire on a organisé dès les
premiers jours du conflit avec la
protection civile une collecte de biens
de première nécessité de bien médicaux
etc et ça a été le plus grand le plus
gros qu'on voit humanitaire jamais
partie de France on l'a peut-être pas
assez dit à l'époque et ça ce sont les
maires de France dans toutes les 35 000
communes qui ont accueilli les réfugiés
et qui ont organisé donc dans les deux
sens une aide humanitaire aujourd'hui il
y a un enjeu aussi qui est majeur c'est
pour ça que j'ai souhaité que l'on fasse
venir des maires craignants j'étais allé
en Ukraine sur la première semaine du
conflit et des maires que je connaissais
déjà d'autres que j'ai rencontré un peu
plus à l'est et j'espère qu'ils pourront
bien venir demain mais l'idée c'est de
montrer que
en Ukraine comme en France comme partout
dans le monde les mers sont toujours en
première ligne sont toujours des
praticiens et ce que j'ai vu là-bas
c'était incroyable
l'accueil de milliers de personnes dans
des gymnases dans des écoles des une
capacité de résistance de solidarité de
d'organisation et donc je crois qu'il
faut mettre en exerg cela et surtout
poser la problématique dès maintenant de
la reconstruction de l'Ukraine en
espérant qu'une solution de paix alors
qu'elle sera telle c'est un autre débat
et que 13 décembre à l'initiative
d'Emmanuel Macron c'est une bonne chose
c'est une bonne chose je le pense oui et
donc nous sommes positionnés très vite
sur la reconstruction pour que apporter
de l'ingénierie juridisco administrative
on a une vraie compétence en France sur
plein de raisons sur l'ingénierie
juridico et administrative pour essayer
d'amener des entreprises françaises
entreprises locales des PME de nos
localités et donc c'est un enjeu majeur
à la fois humanitaire mais aussi
économique et diplomatique l'intérêt et
l'éthique peuvent rejoindre et c'est ce
que nécessaire votre congrès cette année
est placé sous le thème du pouvoir agir
quel est votre état d'esprit ce matin à
l'ouverture de ce congrès en début de
cette semaine alors si c'est mon état
d'esprit personnel c'est un état
d'esprit à la fois concentré sur les
urgences mais je crois pouvoir dire que
c'est le cas de tous les mers c'est
notamment les urgences budgétaires qui
alimentent vos débats ici à juste titre
et comment arriver à passer ce cap de
fin 2022 2023 avec des phénomènes
d'hyperinflation qui frappent encore
plus les communes que que les
entreprises et les ménages et encore
plus que les autres collectivités on
prend en parler si vous voulez sur la
structure budgétaire qui est la nôtre et
puis ensuite d'essayer aussi d'être
proactif dans la durée de d'être des
partenaires loyaux de l'exécutif et et
libre donc parce qu'on peut pas être
loyal si on n'est pas libre et de dire
comment ces défis majeurs le déficitique
moi qui me qui qui m'obsède vous parliez
de de d'état d'esprit je c'est taux
d'abstention record violence sur les
élus cette exagération dans l'expression
publique qui est proportionnelle très
souvent au vide de la raison critique du
propos la démocratie je pense que notre
démocratie elle est elle est en danger
je suis pas pessimiste mais c'est un
thème majeur et si notre démocratie est
en danger si on n'a pas de renouveau
civique on n'arrivera pas à aborder de
façon efficace les grands défis qui sont
les notes des défis écologiques
réchauffement climatiques le défi
numérique prioritaire le défi économique
et social le défi démographique tous ces
défis qui font aussi la grandeur de la
politique
vous disiez il y a quelques jours vous
ne souhaitiez pas flinguer je reprends
votre expression vous l'avez noté vos
discussions avec le sommet de l'État
Emmanuel Macron et Isabelle borne il y a
quelques années votre prédécesseur et
mentor Jacques pélissan c'était pas mal
rapproché d'Emmanuel Macron est-ce qu'en
rapport de confiance du même genre est
envisageable entre vrai chef de l'État
pour ce deuxième sur ce deuxième
quinquennat moi j'utilise souvent une
expression que j'avais lu dans une
biographie ça marche qui disait
j'ai perdu mes illusions mais pas mes
espérances voilà ça sera ma réponse mais
on a un devoir de travail que l'exécutif
quel qu'il soit je l'ai toujours dit
quand j'étais venu sur votre plateau il
y a un an quand j'étais candidat à la
présidence de l'AMF j'ai mes engagements
politiques j'ai mes convictions mes
principes etc de droite oui alors que
ces notions
elle renvoie des vérités qui sont un peu
différentes ça sera ça nous prendrait
pour le coup beaucoup de ça nous ferait
toute la matinale mais mais disons que
je suis attaché à la force de la liberté
comme source d'émancipation et de
prospérité à la force de l'autorité
comme source d'ordre donc de justice et
à la force de l'instruction de la
culture et de la justice comme source
d'unité de la nation et ces trois
objectifs
prospérité par la liberté ordre par
l'autorité unité de la nation ça c'est
trois finalités je crois majeur et je
pense que c'est un petit peu ce qui
distingue lors de libéralisme à droite
enfin on fait ça comme vous voulez pour
revenir à la question donc on a un
devoir travailler avec l'exécutif moi je
le présent République a été réélu euh je
ne soutiens pas politiquement mais mais
qu'importe la MF représente tous les
mers des maires de gauche de droite des
mers qui sont en même temps des mers qui
sont proches de l'exécutif toutes nos
décisions on arrive à les prendre à
l'unanimité et sont pas des positions
molles c'est des positions fortes et
donc là dessus avec responsabilité mais
on essaie de d'aborder
sympathiquement avec le l'exécutif
pendant le précédent quinquennat ça a
été compliqué est-ce que là avec
Elisabeth borne et ce second quinquennat
ça se passe mieux pour qu'il y a une
vingtaine de ministres
avec vous avez compris ma parole était
libre donc responsable mais de même que
je je dénonce la politique qui est menée
qui qui est faite d'en face et théâtre
de façon générale dans cette exécutif je
trouve que la première ministre a une
façon de travailler qui est plus
respectueuse des corps intermédiaires
qui est qui est partenariale avec
l'Association des maires de France
beaucoup plus que ces deux prédécesseurs
du premier quin
mais qui avait une filière inversée un
peu comme on disait quand j'étais plus
jeune de votre famille politique à
l'origine oui alors pas le terme de
famille moi j'ai qu'une famille j'ai des
mouvements politiques mais voilà donc
après avoir dans les actes aujourd'hui
on est en pleine discussion grâce au
travail parlementaire notamment dans
cette maison au Sénat et et aux
relations avec Matignon dans le cadre
qui nous est imposé on essaie de faire
entendre la voix du terrain la voix des
communes et on a eu quelques avancées
vous le savez on pourra y revenir aussi
mais ensuite moi ce que je voulais c'est
qu'on fasse bouger le cadre qu'on sorte
du cadre et c'est là où on attend le
président de la République qui a eu un
changement de discours à 180° sur la
décentralisation lorsqu'il vient en
congrès des mers l'année dernière il a
un discours assez violent d'ailleurs
enfin c'est violent c'est dur sur sur la
décentralisation sur les mers d'ailleurs
etc et puis lorsque je le rencontre le 5
septembre
on sent une convergence de vie par
rapport aux positions de la MF ce qu'il
reprend dans son discours la Mayenne du
10 du 10 octobre sauf que maintenant
nous on veut des actes parce que quand
je dis que j'avais perdu mes illusions
je les discours c'est bien c'est
important mais ensuite il faut qu'on
voit les actes et ce que l'on constate
quand même aujourd'hui c'est qu'il y a
toujours cette tentation très
conformiste tu es très statistique de
reprise d'une tutélisation des
collectivités ce qui est une erreur
historique qui dure depuis 15 ans et qui
est en train de s'accentuer je pense
qu'il faut revoir la fiscalité
économique sur la CVAE mais on aurait pu
faire différemment garder un lien fiscal
avec le local commencez par la
suppression la C3S qui est l'impôt qui
pénalise le plus la compétitivité du
pays mais qui rapporte à l'état c'est
marrant que l'État supprime toujours
l'impôt des autres mais pas les siens
maintenant et ensuite nous met sous
dépense de dotation et ensuite laisse
apparaître le fait comme si les maires
quémandaient ses dotations mais il y a
des engagements solennels qui sont pris
pour nous soit attribuées en suivant
l'inflation évidemment et puis quand
arrive les discussions budgétaires on
dit attendez soyez gentils regardez ce
que l'État vous donne en vous aide j'ai
entendu ça y compris sur votre antenne
mais attendez l'état d'abord c'est nous
tous et il y a eu des engagements qui
ont été pris on nous prive de moyens en
nous transfère des charges et des
responsabilités et ensuite on vendait
nous faire croire qu'on est les
pleurnichards qui demandent de l'argent
à l'état c'est pas le cas le ministre
puisque c'est le cas on dit mais on
augmente la dotation globale de
fonctionnement de manière inédite depuis
13 ans il y a un amortisseur électricité
on aide les collectivités vous dites
c'est pas la hauteur alors pure chose
dans ce que vous avez dit l'amortisseur
électricité on est en train de discuter
il y a eu un engagement fort d'Elisabeth
borne qui a changé d'approche par
rapport au projet loi finance
rectificative avec un dispositif qui
était sans faire de mauvais jeu de mots
pour une usine à gaz très compliquée ce
dispositif va continuer mais on est en
train d'essayer de l'amender ne
serait-ce que sur la baisse de la CAF
qui est un des critères de la capacités
d'attribution moins 25% on espère
arriver à moins 15% comme critères mais
enfin c'est très compliqué mais le
dispositif qui a été annoncé récemment
sur l'amortisseur énergétique avec 2
milliard 5 c'est un bon dispositif qui
reprend les positions de la MF qui a été
la seule association d'élu qui a tenu
bon là-dessus sur l'universalité des
aides enfin et des dispositifs donc on
va voir le contenu le prix pivot qui
avait été vu avec la creux de 325 €, il
nous paraît beaucoup trop élevé mais les
discussions avancent bien en revanche
sur l'histoire de la DGF vous
permettrait de dire que c'est c'est un
peu de l'esbroufe communicationnel c'est
un peu de la comment disait-il la poudre
de perlimpinpin alors justement parce
que
c'est une question qui est très liée et
je pense que vous allez pouvoir répondre
en même temps taxe d'habitation taxe
foncière l'état dit on a compensé la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation
est-ce que vous pouvez dire que la
parole de l'État était tenue sur le
sujet alors je j'attends là on va
laisser passer le maire mais au
printemps le Congrès des mères pardon
mais on démontrera que sur la la taxe
d'habitation il manque à peu près un
milliard dans le dans le dans le voilà
c'est pas rien j'ai pas encore tous les
éléments mais avec André leigniel et le
Comité des finances locales
ce sera un des chantiers que l'on
s'attachera démontrer deuxièmement soit
pas compensé oui parce que mais parce
que là aussi l'expérience nous montre
que
malheureusement depuis 2010 l'État a
tendance à ne pas tenir ses engagements
regardez sur la sur la dotation il faut
toujours rappeler que la dotation c'est
un du ce n'est pas un don c'est pas une
subvention c'est soit des transferts de
compétences donc des transferts de
charges d'où les transferts de recettes
soit des suppressions de fiscalité il y
a eu la taxe professionnelle puis la
taxe d'habitation vous me constaterez
que quand l'État supprime ces fiscalité
les prélèvements obligatoires augmentent
quand même donc ça veut dire que il y a
des prélèvements ailleurs juste pour que
les citoyens ne se fassent pas abuser et
en fait
bien sûr on nous déresponsabilise moi je
suis pour la responsabilité je veux
rendre des comptes je veux je suis pour
l'émulation fiscale la compétition pour
pour que inciter à la vertu à la
sobriété fiscale encore faut-il qu'on
ait des leviers pour sa silo est-ce
qu'un impôt on est complètement pris par
cette par ce levier là sur la dotation
on nous dit plus 20 millions d'euros
formidable il y a jamais eu cette effort
depuis je sais pas combien d'années etc
13 ans mais c'est faut bien comprendre
quand l'indexation quand la DGF la
dotation la DGF n'est pas indexée ce qui
est pas normal c'est depuis 2010 et puis
ensuite il prélèvements 2014 quand il y
a 1 % d'inflation en fait l'étape pioche
1% en neuroconstant dans la dotation
parce que lui il a une dynamique des
recettes plus 35 milliards en 2022
notamment sur la TVA lis et lierre mais
lorsqu'on nous dit regardez c'est pas
figé cette fois-ci on augmente de 320
sauf qu'on n'est pas un pourcent 1,5 %
d'inflation officiellement 4,2 en 2023
en réalité on est plutôt autour de 7 ça
veut dire qu'en fait l'état au lieu de
vous prendre 1% en euros constant il
vous prend l'inflation moins cette
augmentation de 320 millions qui
représente 1,74% si vous êtes sur une
inflation de 5 ben vous faites le calcul
rapidement c'est plus de prélèvement 3%
de prélèvement sur la DGF de l'État donc
c'est de lesroofs et je pense que le
gouvernement a tort de répéter ces
éléments de langage parce que ça énerve
les mères ça veut dire que de fait vous
êtes pris au piège d'une inexorable
augmentation de la taxe foncière non non
d'ailleurs vous verrez sur les les
études que nous avons réalisées auprès
des maires qui va être qui va être
publié dans quelques heures
je pense que le danger il est bien
ailleurs il y a des augmentations de
foncier puisqu'on l'a vu notamment ici à
Paris bon mais
elle est obligé d'augmenter une 50% j'ai
pas les commenter si vous voulez l'AMF
n'a pas commenté les décisions d'une
chaque mer fait ce qu'il veut moi je
suis sur ma commune sur ma commune je
baisse la dette depuis 7 ans une commune
qu'un taux de pauvreté qui est plus du
double de celui de Paris contrairement à
ce qu'on croit baisse la dette depuis 7
ans on fait des économies de
fonctionnement très forte on augmente la
productivité je fais un deuxième plan
CAPEX et on a une sobriété fiscale sur
les taux parce que les les bases elles
suivent l'inflation donc on ne
reconstant c'est stable donc non mais
c'est je répète la MS n'a pas se
positionner là dessus en revanche ce que
je vais vous dire c'est que les mers
vont continuer à faire des économies on
a fait c'est plus de 88% des mers qui
vont réduire encore leurs dépenses et
tant mieux très bien comment on le fait
toujours deux mais ce qui va être
victime de cela de cet effet de ciseaux
c'est l'investissement et il faut jamais
oublier une chose qu'on ne dit jamais
assez c'est que les toutes les
collectivités territoriales françaises
ce qu'on appelle le mille-feuille région
département et le bloc communal
intercommunalité et commune représente
19% du total de la dépense publique en
France en Europe c'est 31% on est en
dessous en termes de dépenses publiques
de défense des collectivités par rapport
au reste de l'Europe Scooby de dire tous
les observateurs en revanche nous
représentons avec les régions et les
départements quasiment 75% et les
communes c'est quasiment 70%. donc ce
qui va être réduit comme la capacité
d'autofinancement va baisser il faut
absolument préserver cette CAF mais elle
va baisser c'est l'investissement et ça
va avoir un effet réceptionniste macro
au-delà des difficultés communes par
commune il va y avoir un effet
macroéconomique négatif ça c'est un très
fort enjeu les artisans etc pardon oui
sur le BTP notamment et d'autres secteur
un dernier mot puisque vous êtes vend
debout contre l'encadrement un de vos
dépenses qui a été réintroduit par 49-3
Christophe BECHU qui était à votre place
jeudi dit qu'il est ouvert à un dialogue
avec le Sénat il reconnaît que ce qui
figure dans les textes actuellement et
plus dur que ce qui avait été négocié
avec vous vous êtes optimiste
quoi donc nous sommes en train de
discuter donc je peux témoigner qu'il y
a une discussion et ce que j'ai expliqué
récemment c'est que on ne sait
s'exprimer pas simplement au Congrès des
mères il faudrait pas que cette
discussion elle vise à un petit peu
annuler l'expression congrès des mœurs
mais je ne veux pas faire de procès
d'intention ce que nous constatons c'est
que les déclarations des engagements qui
avaient été pris était sur l'absence de
retour un dispositif dit de Cahors et
que la réalité ça a été dispositif de
Cahors même plus violent par 49-3
de façon surprise générale alors que
c'était dans le texte de programmation
d'évolution des dépenses publiques qui
lui ne fait pas l'objet de la 42 sera
tout d'un coup c'est réintroduit par un
amendement et ce dispositif porte
atteinte à un principe constitutionnel
qui est celui de libre administration
des collectivités articles 72 de la
Constitution n'a pas de sens comptable
parce que les communes respectent la
règle d'or et donc nous sommes quel que
soit les circonstances obligées de
dégager un excédent de fonctionnement
donc l'état déduit de sa présentation à
Bruxelles cet excellente fonctionner
alors en réalité on essaie de trouver
une sorte de compromis et je pense qu'on
va y arriver avec le travail aussi
parlementaire et nos relations avec
Christophe Béchu et Isabelle borne
peut-être pour une présentation faciale
sur cinq ans montrer à Bruxelles qui
auraient dispositif d'encadrement mais
sans mesures coercitive pour une raison
simple c'est que les collectivités
territoriales et notamment les communes
les mairies de France ne sont pas un
problème pour les comptes publics même
avec les mairies les plus mal gérées
nous dégageons de
là où le chauffage des grands
équipements etc les communes c'est plus
de 200000 mètres carrés
280 millions qu'est-ce que vous dit 280
millions de mètres carrés autrement ce
serait le problème serait vite réglé 200
80 millions et 20000 millions de mètres
carrés pour les communes et les
intercommunalités les gymnases les
écoles les collèges donc il faut
investir il faut trouver des systèmes
qui nous permettent donc il faut qu'on
garde de la capacité d'autofinancement
ce que je vous disais et effectivement
il faut qu'avec l'état on se donne des
objectifs je crois ambitieux de dire à
tel échéance on doit avoir beaucoup
mieux isolé changer nos chaudières et
donc une planification
intelligente de pour mes remplacer des
nouvelles chaudières et bien isoler nos
bâtiments c'est essentiel pour la
planète et pour nos finances il y a une
loi énergie renouvelable qui est
examinée actuellement par le Parlement
elle va arriver à l'Assemblée nationale
elle a été votée par le Sénat au Sénat
un compromis a été trouvé avec le
gouvernement il y a plus de droit de
veto des mers recto-sensus sauf que
Olivier Marleix le président du groupe
les républicains à l'Assemblée lui veut
rétablir ce droit de veto des mers
obligé de favorable nous alors ce qu'on
avait dit avec la MF c'était de dire
d'abord on n'était pas favorable au
droit de véto en covisibilité parce
qu'au départ il y avait des textes pour
permettre aux maires des communes
voisines de la station des équipements
d'exprimer un droit de veto donc la MF a
dit non en revanche on ne veut plus
perdre notre pouvoir d'urbanisme c'est
ça
l'autre côté c'est le pouvoir agir pour
pouvoir agir il faut le pouvoir en
finance on vient d'en parler il faut en
droit or on a une petite élisation et
une affaiblissement notre capacité
d'action depuis une quinzaine d'années
par les schématisations les schémas
directeurs les plans machin truc tout ce
qui est opposable tous ces bidules qui
qui génèrent la bureaucratie qui nous
font perdre du nombre
trop de schémas directeurs il y a une
vision quand même je vais être un peu
provocateur mais après de soviétisme
afin de non je veux pas le dire parce
que ce serait excessif mais
l'organisation territoriale c'est-à-dire
que quand vous regardez je vais pas vous
refaire le l'effet de oratoire de
comme une voilà le secteur où là on peut
mettre des l'éoliens voilà on en met pas
sur quels critères pourquoi tel type de
population peut avoir une éolienne pas
très loin alors il y a eu des avancées
dans ce texte importantes et moi je
pense qu'on va trouver un compromis
acceptable à l'Assemblée nationale et au
Sénat sur la sécurité cette mission de
police le rassemblement national dénonce
une insécurité galopante dans ce pays
vous en tant que président d'association
des maires à l'échelle de vos communes
est-ce que vous partagez ce diagnostic
pour permettez-moi de dire pourquoi
placez-vous le rassemblement national
comme le seul la seule alarme moi
j'entends des élus LR faire le même
constat j'entends des élus socialistes
donc communiste vous partagez diagnostic
aujourd'hui on était dans un mouvement
multicellulaire de baisse de la violence
depuis la Renaissance sauf accident il y
avait une baisse du nombre de crimes
linéaire depuis une dizaine d'années le
nombre d'homicides augmente et ça c'est
pas un biais de statistiques le nom de
domicile par habitant augmente les rixe
au couteau moi je peux vous y allez
statistiques et puis ce que l'on
constate des Rix au couteau c'était
marginal avant on en avait une par mois
peut-être dans des villes très denses
très actives comme la mienne aujourd'hui
c'est devenu malheureusement banal il
faut pas le banaliser donc il y a
manifestement une dégradation de la
situation sécuritaire en France et vous
disiez le maire n'a pas d'autorité
judiciaire on est dans un système qui
est un entre deux et c'est là c'est les
limites du en même temps c'est comme sur
l'immigration on peut pas dire d'un côté
je fais une loi d'immigration parce que
maintenant on va être ferme on va
maîtriser l'immigration puis d'un autre
côté accueillir le le chêne Viking voilà
il y a une contradiction mais en matière
de sécurité c'est la même chose il est
signé doivent être simple il faut des
bureaucratiser la police parce que il y
a beaucoup de moyens en fait en matière
de sécurité en France c'est on a un
nombre d'effectifs de force de l'ordre
qui est plutôt dans la fourchette haute
mais sur le terrain on en a moins
qu'ailleurs et donc c'est un problème et
les maires en zone police très souvent
les mers se substituts mais sans
l'autorité judiciaire et ça devient des
facto un transfert de compétences qu'on
finance nous donc il y a un vrai
problème il faut qu'avec le ministère de
l'intérieur on arrive avec avec Gérard
Darmanin qu'on arrive à mettre à plat
tout cela pour organiser une nouvelle
chaîne de sécurité à nouveau continuum
de sécurité c'est toute l'aspiration de
l'Association des maires de France les
agressions vers les élus se multiplient
est-ce que vous demandez que les
sanctions soient renforcées quand on
agresse un élu en fait on demande que
les sanctions contre enfin il faut
protéger tous les Français pas que les
élus les les élus locaux les mers ce
sont des Français parmi les Français
mandatés parmi les Français il y a une
augmentation exponentielle on a plus de
50% à peu près les agressions sur leurs
agressions y compris verbales et
peut-être le pire c'est quand vous êtes
diffamés lorsque vous êtes salis etc et
donc là dessus on doit être considéré
comme dépositaire de l'autorité publique
c'est le cas de maintenant il y a eu des
avancées récemment et mais c'est comme
toujours ces questions d'exécution des
choses c'est à dire que le droit c'est
pas la loi c'est la loi elle est plutôt
pas mal faite en l'occurrence mais
quelle est la réalité des moyens des
parquets du du procureur pour faire face
à ce flot de dossier vous avez vu cette
circulaire qui a demandé de supprimer je
sais plus combien mais une enfin on dit
qu'on est égaux face à la loi il y a une
directive gouvernementale pour effacer
une nombre de dossiers et donc qui ont
été classés sans suite sans instruction
on va terminer en parlant des
républicains ce soir aura lieu le seul
et unique débat entre les trois
prétendants à la présidence qu'en
attendez-vous qu'elle doit être le
profil du prochain Président pour vous
je serais Christophe Béchu ce soir
donc j'espère
pas du tout pas du tout parce que c'est
ça évidemment je suis concerné je suis
membre de ce parti
mais j'y ai pensé pour ya vous cacher et
et
pour une raison qui qui réelle et elle
me paraît évidente parfois elle surprend
les observateurs c'est que comme je me
suis dit que si je gagnais parce que
après tout on peut gagner j'avais un
problème matériel d'organisation du
temps c'est pas je suis maire de ma
commune c'est qui me prend le plus de
temps c'est ce qui me passionne c'est
c'est mon engagement c'est malin c'est
c'est puis c'est c'est comme dirige une
entreprise quoi c'est H24 je préside
l'AMF qui est une grande et belle maison
chez cet honneur de présider la
situation des maires de France quelle
belle mission c'est très chronophage
aussi et et
imaginons que si on y va c'est pour
gagner et si j'avais gagné je crois que
le travail de redressement du parti est
tellement lourd et tellement important
qu'il nécessite beaucoup plus de temps
que le temps de que pas très favorable
aucune des mandats non moi j'étais
j'étais pas favorable aucune des mandats
mais je crois que j'avais parce que là
c'est pas un mandat c'est pas la même
chose il faut faut quand même remettre
les choses dans l'ordre
en revanche je pense que c'était une
erreur que de supprimer le cumul député
maire au sénateurs je crois
qu'aujourd'hui tout le monde est en
train d'admettre voilà mais c'est un
autre sujet sur votre sur votre partie
Fabrice
on parle des amis
partir de le DLR puisque vous êtes sur
la nature
est-ce que vous êtes inscrit est-ce que
vous êtes inquiet alors j'utilise pas le
terme de famille politique j'ai bien
compris vous avez vécu ailleurs est-ce
que est-ce que vous êtes inquiet sur
l'avenir de ce mouvement politique
est-ce que vous êtes inquiétez des
conséquences que cette disparition cette
éventuelle implosion pourrait poser je
suis très inquiet sur la sur l'état et
l'avenir de la de notre pays et de notre
démocratie ce que vous évoquez tout à
l'heure et donc ce que je crois pour
rattacher à votre question c'est que on
a fait donc on s'est pris une tôle je
sais pas quel est le terme moins trivial
mais enfin c'est pas une déculottée à la
présidentielle pour différentes raisons
4 70 % et que ce qui compte c'est pas
l'avenir de LR ou l'avenir de la droite
ce qui compte c'est que l'on arrive à
rétablir un clivage partisan politique
civilisé moi je crois qu'on a besoin
d'avoir un clivage droit de gauche j'en
suis archi convaincu pour qu'il y ait
des vrais altern pour qu'il y ait des
vrais choix autour et pas faire par des
catalogues de mesure mais par des
principes je pense que le rapport à
l'égalité pas le même entre la gauche à
droite le rapport à la liberté et pas le
même donc l'enjeu aujourd'hui oui je
suis inquiet c'est d'arriver à
reconstruire un mouvement politique qui
soit une force d'alternative claire
nette et qui puisse amener une
dialectique qui sorte de cette
opposition sordide entre l'extrême
centrer pour reprendre une expression
d'Alain Jura Slama l'extrême centrisme
de le en même tempsisme qui godille et
qui crée de l'incivisme à mon sens et
des expressions extrémistes sur le Yaka
faucon et les deux sont deux formes de
démagogie qui s'alimentent vraiment
arrondies le conformisme
c'est celui du pouvoir alimente leur
évolutionnarisme ben moi il me semble
que dans l'intérêt de notre démocratie
de l'intérêt du pays de la vitalité
civique des politiques publiques il faut
retrouver une dialectique gauche droite
moderne différentes respectueuse mais
Claire vous avez pensé à la présidente
que vous pensez à la présidentielle
est-ce que vous préparez votre
candidature je trouve qu'il est tout à
fait incongru et presque irrespectueux
des habitants que de parler tout le
temps de la présidentielle alors qu'on
vient c'est pas moi qui ai voté pour
premier tour en tout cas mais de réélire
un président de la République voilà donc
aujourd'hui ce qu'il faut c'est prendre
les choses les unes après les autres on
a un quinquennat la situation est tendue
difficile dans le pays on doit essayer
d'être le plus utile possible pendant
ces 5 ans et ensuite de préparer une
alternance pour préparer cette
alternance il faut qu'il y ait des
forces politiques fortes et j'espère que
ce sera le cas de Dr moi je développe
mon mouvement depuis 2013 qui s'appelle
nouvel énergie parce que j'y trouve de
la liberté la responsabilité de faire
valoir mes convictions de façon plein et
entière plein de gens formidables me
retrouvent de définir un corpus une
doctrine ce qui nous manque c'est une
doctrine d'affirmer des principes de
faire émerger des talents d'aller
chercher des talents partout de
développer une stratégie numérique bref
et ensuite l'incarnation doit se faire
un an ou deux avant pour préparer la
présidentielle mais autrement pas
maintenant faut pas désigner votre
candidat maintenant c'est ce que vous
dites je pense que c'est une erreur oui
bien sûr je l'ai dit publiquement je
leur ai confirme aujourd'hui je crois
que dire aujourd'hui quelle candidat à
la présidentielle d'abord ça se passe
jamais comme on le pense enfin avoir un
décompte il va se passer quatre ans et
demi quoi je vous laisse filer
malheureusement on aurait encore plein
de questions mais on était bien mais je
crois que vous allez ouvrir je crois que
vous devez ouvrir le Congrès cette
journée les outre-mer qu'on suivra
évidemment direction notre antenne merci
suivre de travaux merci à tous merci
beaucoup David merci Fabrice et on passe
au club